so say you have log base B of X times y
if you expand this you get log base B of
X plus log base B of Y so when you
multiply these are called the arguments
when they're multiplied you can write it
as the sum of two logs you just want to
make sure you keep the same base
whatever this base is space 3 these will
both be base 3 its base 10 the both be
base 10 log base B of X divided by Y
what do we do when we divide we can
expand this by subtracting the two logs
okay so when you divide you take a log
of the numerator minus log of the
denominator so log of the one on top -
log of the one on the bottom again
keeping the same base and then the power
property for logs okay you have this
power okay up here this exponent you can
bring that down in front as a
coefficient so we could write this as n
log base B of X so this is called the
product property product means multiply
you write it as a sum quotient property
you're dividing you write it as a
difference and power property bring down
that power in front as a coefficient
like so now when you go from the left to
the right that's expanding when you go
from the right to the left that's
condensing you're condensing into just
one log so let's take a look at some
examples and let's talk about the
expanding first so say for example you
have log base 2 of 5x squared Y divided
by 3 okay you want to expand this you
want to write it as you know multiple
logs not just one log so what we're
gonna do is notice that the five is
multiplied by x squared x squared is x Y
and the whole thing is divided by three
so what we're going to do is we're going
to expand this out log base two of five
five plus log base 2 of x squared plus
log base two of Y okay minus log base 2
of 3 so we subtracted here because we
were dividing by the 3 here we added
because these are multiplied together
okay and then the last thing we want to
do is we want to bring that power that 2
down in front of the log as a
coefficient so we expanded that one
completely out okay let's look at
another example say we have this one
here log base 4 of X divided by W Y Z
okay now this one oftentimes confuses
students because we have multiple
quantities here in the denominator what
do we do okay well I'm going to show you
so basically what we're gonna do is
we've got log base 4 of X minus log base
4 of W minus log base 4 of Y minus log
base 4 of Z now here's the question that
all the students that I work with ask me
they say well aren't W Y & Z multiplied
together when we multiply don't we add
and that's a good question but here's
the thing
you're right W y and z are multiplied
together so you could think of it like
this is in parentheses okay
these are added right because W y&z were
multiplied together originally here but
they're in the denominator we're
subtracting right but what happens is
see this negative you're distributing
the negative to each one of these logs
so it works out that everything that's
in the denominator will have a minus in
front of that log you'll be subtracting
everything that's in the numerator
you'll have a plus sign or a positive in
front of that log so that's an easy way
to remember anything the denominator are
going to be subtracting those logs
anything in the new
gonna be adding those logs and then of
course if you have a power you're gonna
bring down that power in front of the
coal in front of the log as a
coefficient okay so I'll show one more
example with expanding and then we'll go
on to the condensing just erase these
really quick so okay so now in this next
example what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
make it a little bit more challenging so
say we have log base 7 of the square
root of x ok time is y over Z cubed okay
now here's the first thing 1 I kind of
notice is that X the square root of x is
really like X to what power you could
write this as X to the 1/2 power right
because the square roots of 1/2 power
okay now we're going to get into the
expanding so this is log base 7 of X to
the 1/2 plus because we're multiplying
log base 7 of Y minus log base 7 of Z
cubed so log base 7 of Z to the third
power now what do we do with these
powers the 1/2 and the 3 we bring them
down in front of the log ok so you just
bring those down in front that's fully
expanded and you got it so now let's
talk about okay we did the expanding
let's talk about condensing so let me
just erase this so condensing we're
going from the right side here to the
left side trying to condense it down
into one log so let's look at some
examples for these so let's say we have
log ok and I'll just kind of write log
of W plus 3 log of X minus 2 log of Z
now notice that there's not a base here
what does that mean when there's not a
base means it's a common log it's base
10 it's understood to be based
ten even though they haven't written it
there so what we're gonna do first thing
when we condense we're gonna bring these
coefficients up as powers notice I
didn't bring the negative two just to
just three okay so now what we have for
doing this in steps log W plus log X
cubed minus log Z squared okay now
remember when you add what do you do you
multiply the arguments so we've got log
W X cubed what do you do when you
subtract you divide now remember you
don't want to divide the whole quantity
here just the argument not the log part
just the argument over Z squared and
we've condensed it down into one log
okay so you can see we were adding so we
multiplied we subtracted so we are
dividing by that quantity let me show
you another example great thing about
video is if you want to see that again
just go back a few seconds and you can
redo it okay so now let's look at let's
look at this here Ln X minus Ln Y minus
Ln Z minus Ln 3 ok Ln remember Ellen is
really the natural log and the base here
is base e the natural base e 2.71
approximately so natural log is just log
base E so we're going to condense this
we've got Ln X divided by Y Z and 3 I'm
just gonna write this as 3 Y Z okay now
remember anything that you're
subtracting that's going to go in the
denominator remember subtraction is the
quotient property the other way to think
about this just to kind of bring some
other way of looking at into subtracting
is really like adding the opposite right
so you can bring up this negative 1
power adding the opposite you could
bring up this negative 1 power right
adding the opposite you could bring up
this negative 1 power what does the
negative 1 do to the base
it takes the reciprocal so this becomes
one over Y one over Z one over three now
we're adding so we're multiplying by 1
over Y 1 over Z 1 over 3 and it will end
up in the denominator that way as well
so we've done a couple examples of
expanding and condensing I'll see you in
the next video